[Music]
this morning on the dish drew neporant
he may be the most famous restaurant
tour in the nation
over the last four decades new porn has
made an indelible mark on the food scene
opening a wide range of restaurants
including nobu and tribeca grill while
partnering with a long list of
celebrities
we met up with him in the new york city
neighborhood he helped bring to
prominence
when you opened tribeca grill yeah this
place was
it was different there really wasn't
anything down here except my other
restaurant
down the vlog drew neporance is not a
chef but he knows food better than just
about any of them what's a cut
lamb loin
neporence is a classic front of the
house talent a throwback to when the
person seating people was more important
than the one cooking for them do you
still get the same thrill great greeting
people real is definitely the word yeah
i do
fascinated by all kinds of food from an
early age
his first job was at one of the
mcdonald's that introduced the quarter
pounder to america
nipporan opened his first restaurant in
the mid-80s
mantra shay was a french fine dining
establishment in what was then
considered an outpost neighborhood in
lower manhattan
almost immediately at a time when
newspapers could still make or break you
mantra shay was blessed by the old gray
lady the power that the new york times
had
we got three stars seven weeks after we
opened so guess what that's like winning
the lottery without being able to
collect the cash in 1990 neforence along
with business partner robert de niro
opened the nearby tribeca grill
the neighborhood once a key cog in new
york city's economy was struggling so
badly it became a joke and the
neighborhood is like a demilitarized
zone
hey does this poll still work like when
it housed the original headquarters in
ghostbusters it just seems a little
pricey for a unique fixer-upper
opportunity that's all
helped in part by a roster of a-list
patrons and investors neporan and de
niro's venture quickly transformed new
york's triangle below canal street
better known as tribeca when we opened
tribeca grill robert de niro called bill
murray sean penn mikhail barishnikov lou
diamond phillips ed harris christopher
walker have i dropped enough names so
all those people came in
in 1994 neporent and deniro along with
famed sushi chef nobu matsuhisa opened
the first nobu
here raw seafood became the centerpiece
of the menu
there are now almost 50 locations
worldwide including this one near wall
street
to sample a few nobu classics we sat
down at the bar
still considered one of the most coveted
dining reservations anywhere the first
dish that rio hasagawa is going to make
for us is probably
singularly the most important thing we
serve here we call it yellowtail
jalapeno so it's a hamachi
served with a jalapeno and a
like a yuzu soy
there is a hidden ingredient which i'm
going to ask you about because you're
not going to get it but if you do i'm
going to buy you dinner one night you're
buying me dinner here yeah there you go
there you go the yellowtail jalapeno has
been on the nobu menu since the day they
opened okay should we dig in yeah so you
want to take a tiny piece of the
cilantro and put it on the uh on the
fish as well because that adds to it
it's great
and just the right amount of heat from
the right do you know what the secret
ingredient is i saw him doing something
but i didn't know what it was so you see
on the on the fish there's a slice of
jalapeno yeah
so underneath the jalapeno is a
and i'll tell you what i think i've
eaten
in my own restaurant you know a few
hundred times
there's never been a time that i didn't
order this dish that was followed by
another nobu standard tiradito made with
fluke
each piece topped with a tiny dot of red
chili tiradito typically is a peruvian
dish nobu used to own a restaurant in
peru
and so he was exposed to their way of
dealing with the raw fish i mean i could
eat this any time of the day
you know like any day of the week
up next
some greens look at that
this is our sashimi salad
tuna and sushi sashimi is
really the prized fish
but this one the dressing is so
special it's like unique redolent with
the shallots and garlic
your first snowball experience i feel
very
grateful that you're being able to do it
honored thank you
when we finish the sashimi salad thank
you chef rio expertly assembled a sushi
platter using tuna amberjack salmon
shrimp and cohada it's great to watch
him work yeah at nobu whether it's
preparing the food or consuming it
precision is everything you see now some
people when they pour the soy sauce they
pour so much
like that okay that's all you need this
is the way you do it just go like this
you just turn it and just touch the fish
never the rice just the food never the
rice just the fish fish that's the most
important thing
and
oh my god
i thought
after you say never the right side
jumped don't worry
38 years later neporan's original
restaurant now called batard
also still operates
hey there he is what's happening and
though he'll never admit which one of
the more than 40 restaurants he's opened
is his favorite
as he nears the end of his career
neporan says he'll never be done
searching for that next great idea
so we did good jeff that was great
fantastic thank you thank you rio
rio terrific thank you very much
look at this sampler we have here right
you've got a little bit in front of you
and then no we got the monster are you
going for the yellow team i don't want
to do this so good my clowns will move
right here
so again the key is as i as i learned
here as we learn is it you know you
don't have to go crazy with the soy
sauce right ideally and then it's the
ginger in between dishes okay generally
speaking not on top of oh duh
oh that heat it's like just the right
amount like hits you and then you're
good
and you had no idea with the with the
ginger there or the um yeah that you put
on more coming up right after this